good morning Hank it's Tuesday so over
at youtube.com slash 100 days I'm in the
midst of a health and fitness journey
with my best friend Chris hold up did I
just say I'm on a journey heck on
becoming a self-help book speaking of
which I have long been an avowed enemy
of the motivational quote you know like
tough times don't last but tough people
do or nothing worth having comes easy or
what's the point of being alive if you
don't at least try to do something
remarkable which is actually a quote
from my book an abundance of katherines
so my dad my first problem with
motivational quotes is that like they
aren't true like tough people don't last
like all people they die and many things
that are worth having come easily like
bananas for instance are available at
almost any supermarket for like 50 cents
also hopefully the characters in an
abundance of katherines spend that novel
learning that an unremarkable life can
be fulfilling and meaningful then
there's that old Walt Disney line if you
can dream it you can do it which has
appeared on more posters than Justin
Bieber's face despite being manifestly
untrue like have you ever even had a
dream I once had a dream I was a tuatara
and if the mountain we must conquer
exists within ourselves then why did you
climb all those actual physical
mountains Sir Edmund Hillary you should
have been at home meditating conquering
the mountain within yourself also just
with the record neither Walt Disney nor
Sir Edmund Hillary ever said those
quotes that are so often attributed to
them the motivational quote plague is
perhaps most notable at workout
facilities like the gym where Chris and
I usually work out has this Steve
Prefontaine quote about how giving less
than your best is sacrificing your gift
and a boxing gym we visited had a
handwritten sign reading you don't have
to get ready if you stay ready I find
these little aphorisms not just annoying
but kind of insulting and yet not to
brag or anything but I ran nine miles
yesterday and around mile four I found
myself thinking you don't have to get
ready if you stay ready god help me Hank
I've become a fan of motivational quotes
I'm on a frickin journey I kind of feel
like my whole adult life has been a
series of circumstances that force me to
reckon seriously with stuff I once
easily dismissed like I remember living
in New York in 2007 and railing against
the sheeple buying houses in the Midwest
and now I'm a homeowner in Indianapolis
and I quite like it I used to think that
best-selling books were by definition
crap and then I found myself quickly
backtracking when I unexpectedly became
the author of one I've ridiculed parents
for focusing on their kids instead of
the world's kids only to become a parent
and under
and that impulse and I said that popular
music was dead only to really like
Beyonce's album lemonade but even now I
still haven't learned that when I want
to roll my eyes I should probably be
alive to the possibility that the object
of my disdain is more complex than I'm
imagining and so now yes I have become a
person who revels in cliched usually
misattributed quotes in order to
motivate me toward physical fitness this
is a surprise on several levels not
least because I have long dismissed
physical fitness as a waste of energy
when all that really matters about
humans is their minds but these past few
weeks have already taught me that there
is no hard line between the body and the
brain that running can be good for my
writing and writing good for my running
I kind of thought I'd have to abandon
like my real work for a hundred days
well I focused on my physical health but
instead I'm finding myself enjoying
writing more than I have in years and
even though I'm spending more time
working out weirdly I find that I have
more time for writing too these days I'm
at the keyboard pretty much every day
because you know you don't have to get
ready if you stay ready Hank I'll see
you on Friday and screen for things I
will be at VidCon Europe and Amsterdam
in April with many other youtubers hope
to see you there check out 100 days I
also wanted to let you know that the
10th anniversary vlogbrothers woodcuts
are available for a couple more weeks at
dftba.com and lastly Rosie Ana's
self-care bunny wants you to know that
you are enough